In the Scary Stories series, few
creatures have scared their way so
firmly into our collective conscience as Harold,
The gazing scarecrow that came to life and
wreaked a horrid revenge on its creators.
Thomas and Alfred were cow herders who, in a bid
to stave off boredom, slung together some old
sacks stuffed with straw to make a man-sized doll.
They named this doll “Harold” after another farmer
that they disliked and began abusing it with
curses, kicks, and smearing food on its face.
Then, one day, Harold grunted. Thomas
and Alfred were cautious, temporarily,
but eventually returned to their ways, treating
Harold as a punching bag. Then one day,
Harold stood up, climbed to the roof of their
hut, and began trotting back and forth. Now,
unsure of what Harold was up to, Thomas and
Alfred became uneasy. All night Harold marched
back and forth on the roof of the hut. By
day, Harold would climb down and stand in
a corner of the pasture for hours. Thomas and
Alfred decided it was time to get out of there,
but when they had only gone a mile away,
they realized they were missing a milk
stool. Assuming the living doll couldn’t be
of actual, real, danger, Thomas went back for
the stool while Alfred waited. When Thomas didn’t
return, Alfred went back in search of his friend,
only to find Harold on the roof, laying a
fresh, flayed, human skin out to dry in the sun.
It may be hard to believe, but that
was the toned-down take on Harold. To
learn about how the horror of this old
European folk tale has inspired living
doll legends for hundreds of years,
stick around to the end of this video.
(metal music)
Welcome to Horror History.
You may know Harold from the story “Harold”
included in the book Scary Stories 3: More
Tales to Chill Your Bones, the third collection
in the popular Scary Stories series written by
author Alvin Schwartz. In today’s lesson, we’ll
be exploring Harold’s old European roots, and how
they relate to his legendary counterparts like the
Toggel, Golem, and even Frankenstein’s monster.
“Harold”, is one of the more recognizable
characters from the Scary Stories series.
Though only referred to as a doll in the text, cow
herders Thomas and Alfred do place Harold outside
to scare away birds and the illustration
from Stephen Gammel is more reminiscent
of the traditional scarecrow. In Gammel’s
signature style ink-stained illustration,
Harold stands in a field, tied to a pole, with
his legs spread in a wide stance holding up a
sagging body dressed in old clothes. Thus,
Harold is often referred to and depicted
in modern retellings as a scarecrow but, as
we’ll cover more in-depth later in the video,
in old European folklore, a living
man-sized murder doll is a murder doll:
whether it’s stuffed with hay, made of clay,
or a robot that returns for Judgement Day.
The Scary Stories trilogy books were collections
of short horror stories adapted for kids that
were released in the early 1980s and 90s. The
frightening plots and macabre illustrations
were the oft-cited reasons for banning the
books in many schools. The stories in each
collection are inspired by, if not a retelling
of existing urban legends, historical accounts,
or folklore. Keep in mind, the original material
for most commonly known legends today are usually
pretty rough. Even the Grimm fairy tales
version of Cinderella featured the stepsisters
cutting off parts of their feet to fit the glass
slipper and eventually being blinded by birds.
Death, disfigurement, and blood are common
occurrences in these Harper-Collins books
for ages 9 and up. The third installment alone
features dismemberment, rabid sewer rats,
and literal Death (like, the guy).
Scary Stories 3: More Tales to Chill your Bones,
first released in 1991 and introduced a few new
characters that would be remembered decades later.
“The Red Spot” is a classic urban legend retelling
that provides a good eight-legged reason not to
pick at a zit. “The Dream”, inspired by Victorian
ghost stories, introduced the benevolent thin
and wide smile of the mysterious Pale Woman
or Pale Lady. And Scary Stories 3: More Tales
to Chill Your Bones is where we find Harold.
Preceding the story, the
introductory splash page reads:
“You will say that these stories could
not happen. Yet some say they did happen.”
If something like “Harold” did happen,
we’re going to have to look deep into
the scant details of the story to figure
out his origin. And considering a lot of
the variants of this story also end
with someone being skinned or at the
very least dead, we better start right
now. Enough talking, roll the thing.
(mysterious music)
The story “Harold” contains pretty broad details
but the choices are specific. The names “Thomas”,
“Alfred”, and “Harold” are all of old English
origin and came into popularity around the
middle ages or before the 15th century. Thomas and
Alfred are described in the text as cow herders
who traveled from the valley to the mountains
where they lived in a “hut”. The old English,
Germanic, and Norwegian roots of the word
“hut” also date back to the middle ages.
This points to the story
happening pre-16th century in central Europe.
Then of course there’s the skinning of
Thomas.
While human skinning has been practiced by many cultures at many periods of
time (for various surely reasonable reasons),
the flaying of humans for punishment was
particularly popular during the middle
ages / medieval period, which was from the
5th century to the 15th century respectively.
The only overlap for all of the elements
would be the 15th century in central Europe,
so I’m gonna say it’s set around
then. Good thing for human skinning!
–  Closer.
*CLEAR THROAT* – But this
doesn’t answer the really pressing
question of what is Harold?
In the story, there’s no voodoo incantation,
demonic possession, or ventriloquist’s curse
before the “doll” comes to
life. Harold isn’t possessed by a spirit and,
as far as we can tell, isn’t
stuffed with living insects.
Harold is seemingly willed to existence by
Thomas and Alfred despite neither of them
displaying any sort of supernatural ability. But
this is folklore. Most mass-printed books and
films follow more of a fairy tale structure,
in which some form of explanation is usually
given for the strange occurrences in the
story; along with a more positive ending.
Folklore, while also being entertainment, was and
is more of a means of passing down customs and
traditions. A local legend, even when unpolished
and formless, is a report of a weird, frightful
event, like Mothman in West Virginia or The Jersey
Devil of… well Jersey. The stories don’t always
have a linear narrative direction, though they’ll
often follow similar patterns to a common lesson.
In this case, that “lesson” seems more clear than
the actual reason that Harold comes to life. The
scarecrow is named after a farmer that the two
main characters don’t like, and they use it as an
indirect way to disrespect him. It’s pretty clear
that the lesson is to treat others with respect,
even when they’re not around, and from there, I
would infer that Harold’s incarnation probably
represents the anger of this farmer, that
Thomas and Alfred have most likely mistreated.
But remember, the Scary Stories passage
is only one interpretation of this
legend. Author Alvin Schwartz was an avid
researcher, whose goal with the series was
to inspire the reader to search out folklore
on their own. Which I am now doing for you,
so mission accomplished. An extensive Notes and
Sources section is included at the back of every
Scary Stories collection, sourcing everything
from college-reviewed essays to Life magazines.
According to the resources included in Scary
Stories 3: More Tales to Chill your Bones,
Harold is a retelling of a Swiss-Austrian legend,
The Tunsch Baptized: by the Cowherds
of Göschenen.
In a mountain pasture behind Göschenen, a village
in northern Switzerland, several servants leading
a dissolute life put some odds and ends together
into a Tunsch, also called a Toggel, or a:
Tunggel
Dittitolgg
Dittitunsch
Tschungg
Like Thomas and Alfred, the servants played pranks
and smeared food on the doll until they tried to
baptize it, and they were shocked by the doll
coming to life. The servants recovered quickly
and returned to tormenting their Toggel. Then the
Toggel climbed up and began trotting around the
roof, and the rest is exactly like “Harold”.
Come Autumn, the servants left the pasture,
but they accidentally left a milking
stool behind. One was sent back for it,
and when they looked back on him, they saw
his skin stretched across the roof of the hut.
There are other variants of the “living
doll” tale around central Europe,
but pinpointing the exact origin of this
story may be impossible since this folklore
is descended from oral tradition;
stories passed down by being retold.
Swiss folklore is full of legendary
creatures that were indicative of
the environment and culture, like Frost
Giants, the personification of avalanches,
and Jack Frost, the personification of
winter conditions. A figure of Alpine
folklore who’s received a resurgence in
popularity is the Christmas demon Krampus.
In “Harold”, Thomas and Alfred create a figure for
their own entertainment. When Harold shows signs
of life, they only stop briefly before continuing
to abuse him. By the time they take him seriously,
it’s already too late. Had the two not followed
their hubris into believing they had nothing to
fear from Harold, Thomas might not be a
lampshade in a living scarecrow’s hut.
There’s a phrase associated with this story
trope: “Death by one’s own horse”. Where man is
the greatest danger to himself. In the isolated
communities of pre-Christianity European Alps,
it was a good reminder to be vigilant; that hubris
could be the first step towards accidental death.
Similar legends appear often in old
European folklore, usually repeating
the central theme of the creator killed
by his creation. The Golem of Prague is
a well-known example from the 16th century. It
is said Judah Loew ben Bezalel, the late rabbi,
made the Golem from clay and brought it to life
to defend the Prague ghettos from anti-semitic
attacks. The legend ends familiarly, with
the Golem going on a murderous rampage.
Another example is Mary Shelley’s Frankenstein,
where a Swiss doctor brings to life a man pieced
together from the body parts of the dead only
to lose control of the creature to, of course,
a murderous rampage. James Cameron’s Terminator 2:
Judgment Day can also be considered, as it shows
an android created by the evil corporation Skynet
reprogrammed to fight back against them. More
recently, The Legend of Zelda: Breath of the Wild
puts the player against huge mechanical beasts and
autonomous guardians which were initially created
to protect their civilization, but were hijacked
by the evil Calamity Ganon and yeah, I think you
see the pattern at this point. Murderous rampage.
While The Golem, Frankenstein, T2 and Breath
of the Wild all have the motif seen in the
pre-Christian folklore narrative, they also
all illustrate the effect of the post-medieval
cultural shift from superstition to the use of
reason, the scientific method, and progress.
This is the nature of folklore, the legend spreads
and takes the shape of the culture it’s retold in.
In the 2019 film adaptation, Scary Stories to Tell
in the Dark, the reality is a little twisted. Set
in the 1960s, the in-universe author of the
scary stories is Sarah Bellows, a girl with
albinism who perished after being locked away by
her family. After a hapless group of kids stumbles
upon her magic book, she terrorizes their town
by bringing her original scary stories to life.
In this variation, we first meet Harold
hanging out in a field where local jock
Tommy Milner takes out his frustrations on the
scarecrow each time he passes by.
– [Tommy] Take that!
– [Zac] The fields, and Harold,
belong to Tommy’s family and Tommy is
just begging for an ironic punishment.
As I mentioned earlier, in modern popular
media, there’s usually a reason for supernatural
occurrences beginning. In the film, “Harold”
comes alive as the ghost of Sarah Bellows writes
each scary story in this book. After the “Harold”
story appears on the page, Harold gains sentience,
and Lt. Peaked-In-High-School sucker
punches him on his way through the fields.
– [Tommy] Eat sh*t, Harold.
– The actual story shown on screen seems
similar to the Alvin Schwartz version,
with the name Thomas replaced with Tommy and a
couple details from Tommy Milner’s story thrown
in, such as the fact that he was going to deliver
eggs, which Mrs. Milner had just asked him to do.
– You were supposed to deliver
eggs to the Wolvertons!
– When Tommy passes by Harold’s spot again,
he finds nothing but an empty post,
and he hears something stalking
him before this happens.
(stinger)
With a crack, Harold moves right
before Tommy’s eyes and comes
after him. Tommy is able to find a
pitchfork, but it does very little,
and Harold just pulls it out and jabs
it right back into Tommy’s blindside.
But instead of blood, Tommy sprouts twigs of
hay from all parts of his body and he quickly
transforms into a scarecrow himself. His fate
seems to tell the same old moral in a new way,
with Tommy being forced to become the
object that he for so long abused.
Harold’s story in the film
adaptation doesn’t continue the
old legend’s finale of human skinning, but
the gruesome fate is no fairy tale ending.
– [Stella] It’s what Tommy was wearing last night.
– It’s clear, from the movie adaptation and
the outcry when the original illustrations
were replaced in 2011, that folklore and
story-telling still have some place in the
streaming world. Harold is probably
one of the more famous scarecrows in
literature and he’s never even called a
“scarecrow” in the story. And his iconic
appearance in the movie and prominent
showcasing in all its marketing material
will ensure that future generations
are warned, by the tale of “Harold”.
If you want to learn about other horror icons
with folklore influences, such as The Pale Lady,
check out the playlist on the left. And if
you love horror, remember to subscribe to
CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
the deathbell and select all notifications,
and I will see you in the next
one. Assuming we both survive.
(spooky music)